I have too much to talk
there's probably like four separate
talks that I
two separate talk so some of it I might
go a little fast and I can assume all
you guys know most of this already so
start like Who am I why don't why do I
get to have words of wisdom well they're
not mostly my words of wisdom but I have
this quote from herb Saturn this is my
favorite quote as you can imagine and
it's from this email in the committee
and herbs said Toni's coat is righteous
and then he went on to say and any
coding standard that bans it should be
dragged through sewage and pilloried and
you know and then he says I'll stop
there for politeness but I'm holding
back and he goes okay one more thought
seriously Tony's code follows several
good practices that should be strongly
encouraged including all these things
and let's ignore that that was probably
talking about one specific small example
that I had posted and let's just take
the quote you know like like all good
movie quotes you just take the actually
I am hitting next I just really like the
quote okay I also have one from Buuren
this is this is what you get from yarn
in emails you'll just if you said
something good in the group in the
committee email is just plus one I've
got like five in six years it's like
almost one per year I also got this once
from Erin so I actually got some words
come up we'll come back to that one this
is just to get your brain awake in the
morning you know kind of conflicting
cliches ah okay so oh how am I going to
not do audio but actually play the video
does this work yes yes everyone I don't
need audio because you all know what
that what this was what what's what's he
say here you all very close copy or copy
now there is no shallow
and if we go to master master stepping
off we want to have very simple things
if you construct something with with
another T say then you assume those to
be equal similar if you make default
constructed it and then assign it
assignment does the same as construction
and if you have a and B both equals C
and then you change a then you expect
well a and B are no longer equal but B
is still C and this is a very important
one it says that the copies are disjoint
and they're not sharing any dating
between them because copy or copy not
there is no shadow and does anyone know
what this the scene is this is when he's
talking to a little Anakin at the
beginning I know everyone ignores that
the prequels exist close yes what
something yeah yes State State leads to
suffering state leads to objects objects
leads to references references lead to
sup to sharing sharing leads to
entanglement and hang them and leads to
suffering this this I think is all
obvious to you guys now this the problem
with this of course is you know
programming is a lot about state that's
kind of what our computers do you could
obviously avoid some of it by functional
programming tries to avoid state
completely and just pass values all the
way through but the average programmer
ends you know tends to have state and
then you wrap that state up into classes
and sadly the whole object-oriented
programming thing has equated classes
with objects even though that was that
was like mistake number one
classes are couldn't be values when they
work much better as values but classes
become these object things and and maybe
I'll explain what I mean by objects
versus classes in a second copy-on-write
yeah yes because because it it
externally looks like it follow it
follow Stepan arms axioms right
copy-on-write is fine because you'll
never notice that I'm doing it and also
along with that if you
immutable objects then you can also
share stuff because they never change so
you'll never see that problem of you
know distinctive things so immutable
like pointers to immutable objects act
like value types our reference to
immutable objects yes all those things
require you know more about your
structure your program than just the
type yes I believe it try to touch on
that and once you have objects you tend
to have relationships between the
objects and then we start getting into
what is the structure of your program
and remember that Jedi's should not have
relationships and you know look what
happened to Anakin right thing so and
then we get entanglement and suffering
and that's the path to the dark side
right so what do I mean by object in
value the question my question is is the
queen of clubs an object or a value and
by object I tend to mean things like a
button a button in your in your app is
you think of it as an object it's there
it lives for a long time it changes over
time it's pressed sometimes it's not
pressed whereas you think of intz and
strings and stuff as as values they're
kind of they tend to be either timeless
like the value 17 is always the value 17
forever obviously you're in change in
through the life of your program but
they tend to be kind of kind of
ephemeral where they just are there for
a while then they go away and it's the
value inside the int that is important
not not the int itself of course soon as
you take an int and make it a global
variable
it becomes an object because now it has
this this light or or you just take a
pointer to an int and you pass it around
people now everyone are referring to
this int that lives for extended period
and suddenly it kind of has object like
behavior because objects are things that
change and and then are observable and
have lifetimes and relationships between
other things and when you have objects
you tend to have pointers and say oh now
all pointers and when you have value
types you have oh no pointers
this is how I explained C++ to Java
programmers because they only live in
this world with they don't realize they
have pointers but everything's a pointer
and they're scared of coming over here
because we have pointers and it's like
no just don't have pointers so does
anyone have thoughts on whether the
queen of clubs should be kind of you
know treated like an object in your
program assuming you're writing a game
program card game or should it be
treated like a value because because I
was writing a card program and I ran
into this question and to me it it it
affects like you you can take any type
and turn it into one or the other but I
you know certain things push you in this
direction like I had the queen of clubs
and I thought or like the card class and
I thought I don't want it to be copyable
because suddenly you have two queens of
clubs when you should have only had one
right and sure there's cases in the game
where you have multiple decks or
whatever but you don't want to just
suddenly you know have queen of clubs
sprinkled all over the place so I
started thinking well is it is it like
an object because it's you're you're
trying to represent a physical object or
should it but on the other hand it's
just like rank and and suit it's like to
ins so why isn't it a value so anyone
want to pick aside value you're gonna
say value for anything right yes oh my
god
everything's an object I have to talk
later oh wait wait to my next slide yeah
it's also like it's always the queen of
clubs right act like yeah so well you
know that's why I'm torn this is why
this slide is here because I need you
guys to tell me what how to write this
well maybe right yeah baby
because it's immutable it's it's
everyone treats it as a value because
it's always the same right but but it
also has it has lifetime and it has
relationships because it's in your hand
it's it's in the deck it's where you
know where is it inside the game movable
valium family of values that are move
only yeah yeah it's changeable so your
yeah your your and not only are they
yeah so your I have to repeat this so uh
you know a real deck of cards if you
miss one you take the Joker for example
and rewrite it to be the queen of clubs
and so they're mutable well yeah that's
what he's saying yes so yeah like like
there's only one there's only one
seventeen well-read Gottlob Frege
foundations of arithmetic there might be
more than well I gonna do talk on that
one day
yes but the ability to play the queen of
clubs is movable yeah that's that's true
like to certain sent the queen of clubs
lives in the deck the whole time and all
you get is some is some ownership thing
token should be handed to you a
capability is handed to you and that's
what you hold in your hand
there was Odin was going to say some
okay so for David and people who just
like everything's a value go go watch
one pays talks on postmodern immutable
data structures had to sneak a
postmodern in there and his other one on
the most valuable values and basically
you know even a program that is full of
buttons and things which you really kind
of think is objects you can think of the
whole program as a value and then the
next state of the program is you know a
new value and you can use value
programming you know you do functional
programming basically was what his
doctor but for you Felisa a universe
composed of objects truth is eliminated
I don't you know I don't know if
everything's an object I don't know you
have to you know I soccer is not going
to be speaking in Berlin so you might
win I think something related is a thing
that Sean calls incidental data
structures which if you have say a
contact like the context in your phone
and every contact has a location and for
some reason location is a separate
object and you contact has a pointer to
location and it's like great you've got
you know you think this is an object and
this is an object but really that's your
object right the combined thing is your
object but then if somehow you share a
location between two objects this is not
two overlapping objects this is one
object and this is your data structure
and this is why
Shawn calls him an incidental data
structure because this happens in your
code all the time you've just got code
when everyone's got pointers to these
other things and and the data structure
is just spread out through your whole
code base no one knows what the data
structure of your code base is it's just
people have pointers no one knows where
those pointers are so what Shawn
actually says is find that data
structure and pull it out of your code
base and make it a data structure say
this is what the Photoshop document is
it's all these relationships encapsulate
that into a data structure and then you
can like now the Photoshop document is a
value and you can act on it like a value
because Shawn is also everything is a
value so I think you could do that sort
of kind of we touched on with the queen
of clubs you can say well Lina clubs has
relationship to the deck it has a
relationship to the hands it has
relationship to to where is it on the on
the table and all those kind of things
so the data structure that you are
actually trying to go for is your game
state and ensure you still have inside
that data structure you have other sub
data structures that you want to keep
separate but you have you should
recognize that there is this you know
you are building this bigger data
structure and if you just have it all
over your code base you're not going to
see it if you bring it together into a
class then you can find it yes yeah I
have a card game on my phone where
there's a infinite number of cards so
you get plenty of queens of clubs
popping up and yeah there are cases
where you really do want to be a value
and you want to be caught people and but
yeah and I mean I tried one day I
started this cuz I tried to write a card
game and then I started realizing I
don't want to write a card game I want
to write a deck of cards so that I can
then write any card game and actually
just like have on your phone a deck of
cards and like cuz I don't need to
encode the rules if you had all your
friends all had a deck of cards you just
played like you would with a physical
deck
but you it was on your phone but the
other question there is for for later if
we all have on our phone a card game and
I want to deal the cards fairly and not
cheap and we don't have a server how do
you know that I am NOT cheating in the
protocol of how we talk to each other
blockchain the the easy answer now
exists maybe that is an answer actually
I asked this question sometimes in
interviews and I tell people I do not
know the answer to this question so I do
not expect you to give me an answer to
this question
I just want any idea yes yeah and one of
the best one of the best answers I got
from someone was do you trust your
friends you don't have to do this yeah
it's like it's like yeah and that's true
in coding like somehow people start
having all these requirements on
something and sometimes you have to step
back and go do we really need this do it
like this is gonna be hard so can we
just avoid you know what's the real
business objective or whatever anyhow
another one from Sean shared pointers is
good as a global variable and
Shakespeare neither a borrower nor a
lender be I sometimes use this example
as well when I lend my car to somebody I
can do the keys and you know off you go
I'm not still holding the steering wheel
as long what we know with you as well
right and you could say well the car is
still a a consistent class it object it
whenever the steering wheel is turned it
goes the right way the car doesn't do
anything wrong it's it's you know
completely correct object but to people
holding the steering wheel is a bad idea
right so it's my steering wheel example
this these are just to let you know like
you go to a fancy restaurant and they
serve sorbet between the between the
stages of the meal to cleanse your
palate just here to cleanse your your
mental palate does anyone know this this
one it's not oh wait why is it not
playing oh there goes only a Sith deals
in absolutes and he also goes on pulling
on his lightsaber and so if everybody
says after that but
it's exactly the quote he's talking
about sign verses unsigned of course so
here's my square root function it takes
unsigned int because I can't handle
negatives and well so far it returns
seventeen because I do test-driven
development so so it's correct so far
it's also very fast it's like
second-fastest square root returning
zeros faster if you're wondering but you
know I made it unsigned because I don't
want you passing negative 23 and I'm
declaring it up here it's like look
don't give me negatives so great this
you know this won't happen it's like
well no of course that happens that
that's not a sorry that's not a compiler
you can pass negative 23 in here because
unsigned int is has no strong you know
it's not a very strong type so if you
changed it to some stronger you know
make made your own unsigned int you
could make this a compile error by you
know making an explicit constructor from
from signed whatever you know you can
turn that into a compiler but who's
gonna write their own unsigned yet I'm
saying this is my own class that I wrote
that doesn't accept I will like delete
the int constructor or something
it only takes unsigned int no at first
it's an int I think yeah yeah you have
to delete the in constructor this is
slide where like this right you know I
haven't put the some of it actually some
of the there's a couple cases here I
actually did put in Godbole but not this
one yeah
[Laughter]
here's another example of using unsigned
this is a this there's no compile of
warning at all here at least the
negative 23 into into square root would
give you a warning potentially this
doesn't give you a warning nothing wrong
with that code yes no this is I mean we
didn't write is sorted at work but we
had another algorithm that did exactly
this it had to compare you know the next
one so it went not to the end aside so
this just goes on forever because this
return when it's empty this returns you
know giant number stunts didn't actually
never crashed in our program because we
never had empty in this case but I still
changed it more you quotes from the
Masters all these people on stage go go
watch the talk I've got the time points
where they say don't use on sign and the
last one is just his Chandler saying
sorry for someone's asking why why does
the why does size return on unsigned and
herb says we made a mistake and
challenges so sorry in what's up we were
oh yeah yeah yeah he he also says we
were young which is a what something
Scott often says so you know how do you
combat this is you write your own Oh
first I had the similar problem of in my
codebase we deal with projectors and
cameras and stuff and we have projectors
IDs which are strings and cameras IDs
which are strings so obviously people
are gonna mix up projector IDs and
cameras at camera IDs so what I've done
is written a strong ID class which by
you know this wraps up the string and
acts hardly anything like a string
because it doesn't want to have any
string operators because it's just an ID
it shouldn't change or anything it just
has assignment and whatnot and net with
a tag these are now two different types
camera IDs are not projector IDs and if
you try to mix them up it'll be a
compiler error and if you try to pass
just a string straight in it will be a
compiler error and this is brought to
you by you know this is a quote by our
friend explicit constructor
and I have this giant table that I'm
working on and it's gone through the
committee ones of when should you use
explicit one should you use implicit and
the it's a weird table and I don't
really like the style of it but I'm
working on it if you look at the bottom
you're trying to decide whether to use
an implicit constructor or an implicit
cast if you're going the other way
whether to use an explicit one or
actually don't do either and have a
named function like when you convert a
string to an int or something you don't
want to cast the string to an int you
would call two int or something like
that even though you know you could
definitely don't want to make an
implicit maybe you would someone say
well you can make it explicit it's like
no no you don't cast strings to int you
put a name function on that so the very
top most important thing is is it the
same platonic thing you know meaning
I've got a date class and I got another
date class they both try to represent
the Platonic idea of what a date is
if they're the same thing then you're on
then you can start thinking yes I want
to maybe cast these two between each
other and make it I might even want to
be implicit there might be reasons to
make it explicit but you're on the track
of these are the same they're trying to
represent the same thing if you're not
representing the same thing because
one's a string and one is an integer and
those do not even if a string can hold
the string of an int they're not trying
to represent the same thing therefore
you say no to the first question and you
end up somewhere in this category and
you answer all the questions about like
sort of is it the same thing and then
also well it's trying to represent the
same thing but I lose some fidelity and
then maybe you know like narrowing
conversions and stuff like that you
might want to make it explicit and then
is there a performance penalty because I
mean vector copy has a performance
penalty and we just say that's fine kind
of because we know the size of the
vector and the performance is measurable
like is similar to the size of the
vector but if you had a class where the
constructor did something really heavy
weight you'd probably want to make it
explicit so it doesn't just happen you
know when you're passing functions along
or something and then you also have to
think about whether it throws whether it
you know leaves kind of a dangling
pointers around and stuff like that code
review is an interesting one if you need
to actually keep an eye on where people
are making this conversion then you want
to be able to grep it which means you
want to give it a name right yes yeah
string chart charts are string I don't
know the one that gets me is I for a
while I used to think that you know if
it throws it probably should be explicit
but like string copy constructor throws
you don't want to make that explicit
right and it's sort of it's still a long
those same size you you kind of can just
look at it no yes that that string
constructor is about the Sun you know is
about the performance is about the same
size of the string you pass in right so
I don't know this is why this is like
all question marks it's like there's not
necessarily easy answers yes
then so that yeah this is what this is
why this is a hard thing to explain you
have to think of your class in your head
answer these questions for your class
and if your answer is no you're in this
column if your answer is yes you're
you're in that column all right
and it basically comes down to if you
you you only get implicit if you
basically answer all of these cracks
soon as you answer something in this
column you you have to stay in this
column and if you answer one thing in
this column you have to stay in that
column give or take you know maybe
you'll let one go but if you the more
you start going into this column that's
where you have to live you are talking
about pair classes often you're only in
control of one of them right often only
one of them is in front of the committee
and and we often forget to even consider
hey did you make that explicit and
somewhere yet that the one down here
are you sure is kind of is kind of we
should just default to explicit and and
and there's actually some Community
Guidelines
library guidelines document somewhere
that says
says that default to explicit and then
explain why if your class says no no
this can be implicit here you'll have to
explain it to us so that's that's on my
my github and it's also being in front
of the committee once but it's it is a
hard to understand table but here's an
another example that I came across when
I was doing that if I have an image
class that you know takes a filename and
you know hopefully it's a JPEG or
something makes an image out of it you
know and then I can construct it like
that and I can also cast it I can now
cast string to image which I you know in
our static cast or whatever but that
just seems weird to me that is just that
looks weird that should not be allowed
but I can't I can't get rid of that like
that's explicit constructor you know you
were explicit you you typed the name but
I kind of wish cast wasn't always just
oh you have a constructor therefore cast
just works that feels odd to me but I
don't think we're ever gonna change that
yeah yeah well no it's not quite I look
at this as you're like cuz I'm the
old-school CGI this is like you're
trying to change these bits into those
bits it doesn't look like you're
constructing an image you're trying to
cast you're trying to like just you know
tell the compiler trust me I know what
I'm doing this is this this drink and
can you know is I mean it's not a
reinterpret cast but you know it could
be because it's C style it could be
anything named constructors yeah you
know that would clear up a lot of this
stuff but I don't think we want to go
there either but for that one yes I mean
yeah maybe for this you a factory
function would have been better said
such that you know you can't you have to
name it because because it's also it's a
very heavyweight constructor and it can
fail and all these other things right so
it's probably I probably wouldn't make
that a constructor
I would I would have a function that
called called low JPEG also because your
image class shouldn't have all your file
reading stuff in it like that's totally
image class should just hold pixels I
don't have an image class that does this
so I have a strong ID type and Jonathan
has a strong ID type and John the other
Jonathan John has a strong ID type and
the other one is Bjorn faller has you
know and there's plenty of them so go
out there and find one and use it
this one's there cuz it reminds me a
herb again
so ah well you know among all the quote
some of the quotes I have I don't know
where they came from because this is
just an ancient C++ comb it's been
passed down to down the ages so you know
you got the student who has this crazy
class that just does the right thing all
the time you know you pass it and it
goes oh yeah I'll modify myself to do I
know what you wanted and everything and
then the master hammers are screw into
the desk does that make sense to anyone
cones aren't supposed to make sense at
the beginning and I'm not supposed to
explain them to you but you know Victor
boule is an example of you know oh I'll
be smart and I'll do the right thing I
know what you really want and and I just
think that's that that's bad API right
to have this class that morphs yes
rousseff threats so what is the world's
best API anyone wanna get I was I'm
expecting someone to eventually say the
closing curly bracket which is a really
nice API and all your destructors get
called and everything but it is kind of
subtle so maybe it's not about world's
best API this is the world's best API
ever anyone not know how a hammer works
right if you know anything about physics
and I don't mean you took a course in
physics but you live in the physical
world you can understand how a hammer
works right it's a me as a kid you did
have to kind of learn you know more how
your arm works then how the hammer works
oh yeah that there's this the the the
undo
that is true that's but it is very
obvious how this API works right and and
that's how we should write our API so
it's very clear and obviously that oh
I'm going to take this piece of API and
I take this other piece of API and if I
put them together if for some reason I
want to hammer a screw with you know hit
a hit a screw with a hammer don't
question me don't suddenly go well so
that's that's where this comes from by
the way don't suddenly go I see you're
trying to do something with the screw
did you want me to turn the hammer into
a screwdriver and you know part of the
reason I hammer is obvious is because
you can see its implementation but like
I don't mean you have to have api's
where it's just like here's how I work
exactly how I work so you know how I you
know but you know even this hammer you
can't see what's behind the you know
what's underneath here you know you kind
of assume the metal keeps going I used
to do roofing stringing in high school
university it's like I I had to hear
more just like this where it's really
thin here and everything beautiful this
is the best hammer it's like I still
have mine I kept it from the guy who I
worked for like can I have this hammer
it's really nice hammer but anyhow you
know you know does does the metal you
don't need to know everything about how
the hammer works you just need to know
the external properties of hammer and
they have to be obvious again the
steering wheel is another example you
don't exactly know you don't the look at
how the steering wheel is connected to
your wheels to understand it's just a
very obvious cause-and-effect you go
this way the car goes that way you know
you could write you could make a car
where it went the opposite way you steer
this way and the car goes that way you
probably get used to it eventually but
you know it's nice when api's are
obvious what they do and then as a
programmer you want you don't want I
don't think we're at the stage where we
want our api's to be like Siri that just
you know you ask it stuff and it's it's
magically smart right you want api's
that are just obvious what they do and
then as a programmer I will put these
pieces together and it'll do the obvious
thing that I wanted because I put them
together that way
yes yeah yeah modern-day steering wheels
have a million buttons on them and you
know they're no longer simple api's
right and they're trying to do well that
is a case of you now have an API that is
doing too many things at once because
that is not what the purpose of that ape
of this API was anymore you've just
tacked more things on to it that should
have been somewhere else or it's really
useful you know it's nice having those
buttons on the steering wheel well it's
a throw just because you just talked to
it as a phone speak to it so yeah that
that's feature creep on the hammer
anyhow let's see where we are okay I'm
not going to make it to the end so you
know obviously the quotes aren't from
Ben but the combination the combination
is from Ben I was worried that he's I'm
now worried that he said he said this to
even one time and she's gonna like see
this and go hey Ben were you thinking
this at the don't to want to get him in
trouble or anything Shakespeare what's
in a name that which we call a rose by
in a word would smell sweet this there's
the question whether this is supposed to
be named or word it's because there's
different copies of Shakespeare that
were you know floating around at the
time and people have pieced together
Shakespeare well actually this there's
been studies done on this arose by a
different name doesn't smell a sweet
this has been so they've gave people
various fragrances either with a you
know a nice name or introduce it with a
you know not nice name and then you're
asked to smell it and rate the
fragrances and all this stuff and it
comes out you you perceived it as less
sweet if it had a different name so
programming is not oh it doesn't matter
the name it'll still smell as sweet or
you know they the class was just be as
good with a different name
no Shakespeare was you know has some
good programming parts to him but this
was one one where he he got wrong I like
Michael better essence is the essence of
naming so I guess there's at least one
quote by me in here I actually have a
whole pile of rules of naming that will
definitely turn into a talk someday but
essence is the essence of naming it so
often you have this class it does some
stuff and everything but you're like you
don't know what to call it and until you
know what to call it you go oh this
class is this as soon as you get figure
out what to call it you now know all the
every ever every other question about
that class can refer back to well the
class is this so I can now answer your
question about this API so right now I
you know the the thing we've been ving I
guess I don't want to call it whipping
boy or whatever that's a bad phrase but
the thing we've been picking on lately
is span in the in the standards
committee and to me span has this name
but it doesn't know what it is yet
because it's like well it represents
these the elements in like if you've got
a vector you can have a span that's the
that represents the pointer plus the
length of the sub range in the vector or
whatever but then is you know is the
span just the pointer plus value or is
the span the values that it's pointing
to and you know what and so as soon as
you start asking questions like what
does equal equal do what does what does
copy do what what can become you know
what happens when you make the span
Const is the art - does that make the
elements Const all these questions is
your cut and and currently in the span
we have answers each question subtly you
know it's kind of like the queen of
clubs it's like oh I'm half this and I'm
half that and I think if you were to
name it
spanning pointer and you'd be like oh I
know exactly what this does now it acts
like a pointer so that when you copy two
of them and it would be like pointer or
B she'll like everything will be shallow
like equal equal it would be shallow
copy will be shallow and and I know
because it's called spanning pointer to
expect like point
like semantics and then if we instead
called it spanning wrath
you'd be like oh there's like ref like
semantics at least it's a hint as to you
know it's trying to represent it's
trying to be the elements that it's that
it's pointing to so that equal equal is
deep and it compares the elements yes
yes that's the other thing why not just
have both classes and then see which one
wins maybe yeah both but well yeah we
could have two classes that that are
both useful in different in different
places I prefer one of them myself but
you know we'll get there this is my
paper I sent to the committee in exactly
how else do you make diagrams so the
question is this span regular and it
kind of relies on right now right now
span when you copy a span it's shallow
it just copies the pointer the pointer
in the length but when you compare spans
it's deep it compares the elements that
it's pointing to which can be useful but
it breaks all those stepping offs rules
and and all the stl is built on stepping
offs rules so if you just say yeah I
know it's not regular but I like it that
way then I think it should be it's kind
of spanning ref and it kind of gives you
a clue that we all know that references
aren't normal in C++ we're all like hey
references act a bit weird so you know
that's that's a clue that this isn't
what you expected the next question is
whether Const is deep so if the span
points to these elements and you make a
const span so think about a unique point
or a shared pointer if you have a Const
unique pointer the thing it points to
isn't Const just the pointers is cause
the pointer doesn't change
currently span follows that paradigm
where oh this bans Const you can't
change the you know what the pan points
to but the elements aren't caused yet
the elements are part of its equal equal
so that means I mean do I have oh I miss
that slide so that means if you if you
have a span it's in this paper here if
you have a span and you it's a Const an
and you pass it to a function that takes
a con span when it comes back out it
might not be equal to what it used to be
because equal equal is deep and you
could have changed the underlying things
so I think if span has deep equality it
must have deep consonants because it's
like logical constant the things that
you are trying to be are all Const
you're trying to say I kind of own those
values you mean you don't own the
lifetime of the values you're trying to
say those values are a part of my value
so if I'm constant and they should be
cost of course this gets into problems
with mutability the other rule we have
in the standard is if you have something
Const it's thread-safe
and can't span that points to these
elements that doesn't actually own isn't
thread-safe because those elements can
still be changing somewhere string of
you probably currently has the same
problem like string view equal equal
which is also deep is probably a Const
function but it's not really a Const
function because it's not thread safe
Const iterators well yeah there yeah
yeah I mean some of it comes down to you
know you're implying a contract with the
programmer it's like be aware you know
but some of them are more subtle than
others right yeah yeah constant
constants trying consider aiders are
trying to to pull out now so if you call
C begin to get a Const iterator to a
certain sent your line because the thing
can still be changed getting a constant
area from a Const vector is less lying
because like oh the vector and you know
cost is a total lie everywhere because
it can still change by someone else who
doesn't have a constant it but you know
you're trying to set up some knowledge
with the user of like look this is
constructs me it's constant so I mean I
think this one is really weird if equal
equals cost but equal equal is deep with
cost isn't and then constant deep assign
when you assign a one span from another
span it doesn't change all the elements
right it just it just makes the span
point somewhere else it rebind the span
as if you're rebinding a reference so
even though the value of this band is
the elements when you assign to a span
it doesn't change the value of the
elements which are its value
so that's just me picking on span um if
you can't name me you probably don't
know what it is you don't know what it
is you don't know what it isn't if you
don't know what it isn't you don't know
what code shouldn't be in it and so much
code shouldn't be in it this is this is
what you know
listen span doesn't have this problem
but so much code has this problem right
yes yes yes so let me try to answer your
question yeah a name is for the people
that use it so that they have their
expectations and I think both of these
names will give you a better expectation
than the name span span I'm like I'm not
sure what this does these and I still
don't know exactly what it does I still
have to read the docs and everything but
you want to be like you know hit the
road running you kind of know what this
thing does and maybe you can just look
at code and not be surprised by what it
does this this you will never be
surprised by what you don't have to do
you know you can just look at code know
what this does uses of it but but the
other half of sure the name is to let
other people know what it is but the
name also hones in for you designing the
class what it is so that you know a
month later when you go to add something
to that class you go no this is not what
that class is this class is this so four
four pieces of API you haven't written
yet having a good name means you have a
good idea of what the class really is ah
yes an API is defined by the code that
uses it okay what do you mean in this
case well yeah okay yeah your class is
defined by the code that uses it so if
you pick a right name it'll get used the
way you were hoping it would be used
a hashtag is owned by the by the
movement that adopts it yes and and and
that's the other part of like my last
talk about api's somewhere in there it's
like whatever it is you have to live
with that forever yeah so yes yes yes
this is that I'm trying to get at like
your words where the the name describes
the algebra of the of the type and and
and yeah everything else just starts
falling everything all your other
questions become easy once you've got
the right name because you've I had a I
had a really good developer student that
working for me who is now the manager
but W premier in like just a few years
just it's really good he but he he could
refactor code better than anyone I ever
worked with and we just refactor
everything and then he had always had
like these base classes called common
because it's just like I refactored it
all to here and I'm like what is that
class he's like it's the common stuff
right it's like okay you don't know what
this class is cuz you can't name it so
maybe some of those things even though
it was common maybe they don't belong
there
first decide what what is the meaning of
this class you know having a name the
right name will help you know what the
meaning of the class is then you'll
decide oh even though this is common
amongst everything right now it might
not be common in the future so it
shouldn't be you know here things like
that I'm sure he learned that was when
he was a young student it's better now
affordance yes hammer has affordance an
eggplant doesn't well so some people it
probably does yes yes yes view view yeah
like you started with the hashtags get
get turned into whatever the movement
follows view so far in the standard
means Kant's because you can't you can
look at something but you you know its
look don't touch that's what that's what
view means in in the stand are now only
represented by string view it's the only
view we have ranges are about to show up
and they've used view to mean some you
know to have it's different meaning and
you can modify the things you're viewing
because like you can see it and then you
and then you go and touch it the it's
it's view is probably not the right name
but seriously there is no other name
because the other important property
that we want with a view in the range of
sense is that you don't own this it's
it's elsewhere you need this like
separation quality yes Const reference
yeah
well the difference is that it's shorter
yeah that is basically at view and in
ranges view isn't a class it's a
namespace so you have a bunch of things
that are viewed so you view Co uncle on
this vehicle uncle on that so you want
it short name you know vu its sits
shorter
so the number one rule of API design is
be consistent because the more
consistent you are the less people have
to learn it just everything seems
natural QT is actually you know there's
things I don't like about QT but QT is
consistent once you know how QT works Oh
does this class have a is valid yes it
does because they all do you know or
whatever it's but this I'm gonna mention
this consistent warning signs because
it's a new rule I've just added in the
last year or so going back to my strong
ID class sometimes you do want to get
like I've got a function takes a string
and I can't pass a projector ID in it
but I actually do want the string of the
projector ID maybe I'm just printing it
out or whatever reason showing it to the
user something so I so I static cast it
right which is a little ugly people
don't like typing that so what people do
is they go takes a string for my own
projector ID dot and then the IDE says
Oh operator string is that what you
wanted to call and then they go awesome
and semicolon they're done and and this
was in this is in my code base it's just
like it gets the job done and he
actually it actually is kind of like I
know what you're doing like it's it is
obvious what's going on here you know
and at dot as string would have been a
better function but my shrah ID class
can work on integer strings whatever so
I can't name the functions I don't know
what the type is so this is like as
close as you can get to as string you
know but I was like oh god I you know
that's that's not what I want and no one
sees when you do project your ID dot you
don't see this as an option you know
that the ID says oh maybe you wanted to
throw this code in it's like no it only
offers you this so I need a function
here for when yes I'm going to allow you
to get the get the underlying string so
a function that gets the underlying
value of a wrapped type what should that
function be called if you already know
it have gone through this conversation
with me but
unique pointer calls it get has
underlined just like because I don't
know what it is as well whatever yeah
unwrapped yeah as angle brackets and
does it just not compile if you get the
wrong thing or is it try to convert like
if I if I have this and I say as int
yeah not not half the time but some of
the times it's only half the time if you
write a bunch of template code yeah
outside of templates it's okay right so
you know I had narrowed down to get
value you know just dot value optional
uses duck value unique pointer and
friends use get dot unwrapped you know I
had all these in mind so why pick one
over the other right
and consistent warning sign is what I
wanted and it wasn't till yet I think
was with you on we were tweeting back
and forth and you pointed out that like
dot value is is not an optional is not
as scary as dot get on on unique pointer
right when you see dot get you're like
oh code review why are you calling dot
get on this unique pointer your break
you know you don't do that every day
it's like oh you look at the codes okay
and see why you're doing that because
you you know this API takes takes and
under you know takes a raw pointer so
you have to do dot get on the unique
pointer and it's okay because it doesn't
keep it yeah you're not breaking the the
invariance of unique pointer by calling
you get but you you you know it's a
warning sign that you might be breaking
the invariants of unique pointer and and
it's a warning sign of you are tearing
away in abstraction a layer of
abstraction and that is exactly what's
happening here is that ya know low let
me get you know i can i can now grep
unfortunately get is a really bad name
you know but to a certain extent you can
grab dot get or something to see and
you're just used to looking for it you
know it's hard to grep the code base but
it's not hard to grab in a code review
because you've already trained your eye
to see get as a wait a second i need to
take a quick look at
you know is that okay here you look at
this case you know oh I see what you're
doing fine dot get is fine here but if
someone calls dot get on your projector
IDs all over the codebase you're like
wait a second those functions make them
take a dot projector ID you know like
push push projector ID through the code
base instead of calling dot get
everywhere saying with unique pointer
why don't you make that other function
taking unique pointer as well or
whatever the right thing to do is right
so I think that idea of consistent
warning sign is an important idea
standard get has a problem because
standard get on a tuple never fails
there's nothing wrong with calling
standard get a tuple you do this all the
time
standard get on a variant throws so it's
like that's a slightly different you
know it should have a slightly elevated
set of you know keep an eye out for that
well how do you keep an eye out for that
but not for the other one right but we
called them both standard get other bad
reasons for calling both standard get as
well but how they interact with
structured findings and stuff but some
when people have their hand up yep yes
this is once you it's only worked when
you have a consistent API once you have
a really consistent you can be glaringly
inconsistent in a case and and the
canonical case is is optional expected
in any all have a dot has value and it
all does the same thing it tells you
whether there's a value inside of the of
that object because they can be not have
a Knothole to value now let's add
variant variant has valueless by
exception that is like do not call me
right this is it's not has value because
and it's actually the opposite right
it's like has doesn't have value right
and it's nothing is the same between
these because it shouldn't be the same
you should not be calling has value on a
variant this that never never used this
function maybe in a catch clause you can
use this function but basically try not
to use this function
because your van should never get into
this state it's it's you have to have
move constructors that throw-in up we
things it's not the only case but it's a
rare case and and you shouldn't have to
worry about it you should write your
types such that they don't throw so much
and you won't you won't get into this
situation I saw hands almost you're
thinking about are you alright so this
is when Jusuf said nice real fun by the
way this was somewhat in an email and
committee I talked about being glaringly
inconsistent with naming so I got more
than a plus-one I take those plus ones
and these things and I print them out
and put them on my wall at work so
people discuss things I'm like it's true
step said plus one to that don't don't
argue with me
ah another clash earlybird you know you
guys can look at that I know what I
should these are these are for you guys
to read while I look at what I'm
supposed to be thinking about next and
look at where we are in time well good
we're good with time and sooth I know
not why all code so bad it worries me
you say it worries you so again like
Shakespeare there's lots of copies of
Shakespeare's plays and they kind of get
mixed up so this is from the coder of
Venice some people have seen The
Merchant of Venice which is in sooth I
know not why I am so sad it worries me
you say it worries you which I could
also just put up here and I'll mention
that the person who says is the opening
lines of merchants or coda of Venice
spoken by Antonio so thus I get to rant
now and all my experience tells me that
the main cause of unmaintainable code is
that piece of code are not kept
independent I don't care about ooh the
language where you put your brackets
whatever I just care about keeping your
code isolated and named things well
which is also goes that other quote
about you know if you can name it well
that you can know what code doesn't
belong no that quote yeah did I did I
already have that quote yes
right it's the whole slide it's got the
name that stuff behind it the other one
of these is a map map is incorrectly
named map should be called ordered map
right map and anything what's the big
deal it's like but as soon as you call
it map everyone expects every class to
just work with it and also I swear 99%
of the code doesn't care that it was
ordered it's just I just used the map
because I needed a map and it's that was
the name but and same was set all right
you you have set you think oh I can take
all my things and put them into a set
and yeah you know naivety you might even
think as long as I have equal equal I
should be able to put him into a set of
course you know you need less than and
everything but it leads also to why
doesn't every class just work with map
and set and there and therefore why
doesn't every class just have a lesson
operator and you know herb and I tend to
disagree on this point but I'm like I
can make a chair class that has how many
legs and what color is the chair and all
the properties of a chair inside a class
and then if we just defaulted less to
just work then I could say this chair is
less than that chair and I don't I don't
know what that means
it's just like well it's less it's less
based on the order I put the member
variables or whatever right like I put
color first so black chairs are less
than white chairs yes yeah yeah you just
want some order and at one point I tried
to get that to be if you have a map or a
set the defaults to standard less why
doesn't it default to something that you
know like check that you have standard
less or not and then do standard order
and there's some kind of API problems
but we could just make standard less you
know context for if
inside of Stan or less to say oh you
don't have a less than I will call
default ordering so that now everything
works with sets without having to have a
less than on your class I'm wondering
about that that was in one of her papers
as well because I bugged him about it
but I think if map and set
we're from day one called sorted or
ordered map and ordered set you your
expectations when it would have been
different right
and you would have also realized that
they're ordered and that might be useful
yes it's it's like set I should be able
to put any class into a set because it's
a set of things that's what a set is
right math it's a set when it's an
ordered set and I'm like oh my things
need to be orderable you know the fact
that set has requires ordering is like
an implementation detail almost but
particularly like some people use set
and they use the property that it's
ordered but the vast majority people
don't they just use it as a set so to
most people the fact that York lot your
type needs to be ordered is an
implementation detail that's leaking out
of the interface well well you know all
classes that our value types should have
equal equal that that that we should
just that we we should generate that and
I'm still going to write a paper someday
saying we just generate equal equal for
you so that isn't surprising you know
what is surprising is that set doesn't
need equal equal it only needs less than
it's just you know if it's not less than
or not greater it must be equal yes
[Music]
yeah yeah
set implies equal equals and yes a
partial map instead our map yeah it's
not a yeah in the mathematical sense it
doesn't map this this domain or whatever
to to whatever that you know man I was a
peer mathematician when its upon time
but can't remember aliens I can I can
let that one go I don't need to call it
partial map I just need you know people
just sliding a map from A to B it can
hold any integer so it can be closed or
whatever the word is I'm looking for and
this is my other aunt abstraction
doesn't need to stop at the class border
which is I see all the time and don't
read the rest of it because I will just
show you some slides and this is this is
where I get to pick on Jonathan and I
will say you should read his blogs
they're awesome and I'm stealing
something out of his blog which wasn't
the point of his blog he had a different
point therefore his code looks a certain
way for a certain reason but it's when
some of this start to dawn on me as a
thing that I should push for so this
question is if you have an event system
where events come in and people want to
hear about those events whether those
events are like mousedown
or it's like low memory or doesn't
matter what the events are but you're
like I want to register when this event
happens you know call me on a callback
right
there's you know millions of these
systems are out there so many of them
when I saw this log I thought hey I just
wrote that a month ago you know so and
here's his and his is called the event
mediator and that's what mines called
mediators so it's like that close to be
the same thing and so the question is
how are you storing these you want to
have for this event you have these
listeners right and you want to either
store that as a map from event - you
know list of vector of listeners when I
say list I mean back
list of listeners or you can have a
multi map so you let's start with map of
vector right so then map of vector you
find is anyone listen to this you get a
whole list of people listening you if
there if there's anyone at all listening
you go through the list right very
simple code this all makes sense if it's
a multi map then you call equal range on
the multi map because you have multiple
people all mapped you know we have the
mouse down maps to this guy mouse down
maps to that other guy mouse down maps
to you know there's five different
entries that say mouse down maps to
these people so you call equal range and
then you iterate over the range I didn't
take your I should taking your for each
one but whatever you know also very
simple code and and report the point of
his talk is like of his blog is you know
it's slightly structured differently
this has an is kind of more nested than
the other one and you know your there's
properties and there might be reasons
why you choose one over the other right
but as soon as I saw says like Oh what
do I do in my code and and think about
what is this this function trying to do
right it's trying to get the listeners
and then call them so my code gets the
listeners and then calls them this -
this is pretty much exactly my code
except for I don't use auto usually but
I wanted to be consistent and I've got
comments in mind because I've got
locking that you know you should never
hold a lock when you call unknown code
right and it's really hard I have a
whole talk I did here on how to make a
listener that can can do locking without
without dead locking and and my code
base doesn't do it the right way either
because it's hard but this is the same
as the other code but you notice in this
code the question of which data
structure did you use doesn't exist
right yeah I've abstract it away the
data structure it's like that's all
there is and why don't we code this way
more and you know I'm like really happy
that I like this wasn't a refactoring in
my code base this is just the way it I
typed it
you know right from the start just like
I need listeners and then I need you
know but then this is also my code this
is my lock free code and this is one
giant function that that does lock free
stuff in lock free is one of those cases
where it's like man I need to have
everything all the state in my head at
once because like I have to keep track
of what's going on it's really
complicated but when I gave that talk
again this year I said no I should
really follow my own guidelines and
write it like this right so this is push
now it's like find the tail try to write
to the tail the only reason you have to
loop is because it's lock free and you
might not even if you found the tail it
might not be there when you go to write
so that code is the same as that code
but this one you can understand right
and I've broken down this is this is all
that code pulled out in two separate
functions right now this this is easy to
understand so I'm very guilty as we all
are of writing code like this and we
should be writing code like that I think
ok this one's from Phil so everyone know
this one this one no this is prequel to
three Palin what's was going you know
yeah we're smarter than this that's so
that's anakin says we're smarter than
this or no sorry obi-wan says we're
smarter than this because they've been
trapped in the force field and Anakin
says apparently not because they were
dropped in a force field okay - great
Jedi's somehow you know of course
they've got the Chancellor there that
might be the reason so why why why are
we in this date like I think we're all
smarter than the way we code but
apparently not because the code I see
the code I write not just you know I'm
as guilty is that all of us the code I
write and we have some we have some
reasons or excuses whichever way you
want to look at it the obvious time
crunch you don't have time to write good
code I think instigation is a big
problem right you want to write some
code and see it work as fast as you can
and you just want like you want to see
especially when you
in UI cody was like get that UI up and
running and oh I can see it now I can
like play with my code by clicking on
buttons and stuff and like I see the
code happen and I feel like there's this
80/20 rule going on right everyone we
know is like the first 80% of the code
and then it's 20% takes the second 80%
of the time and to me that is like not
that I run marathons like I can't even
walk a marathon but you know marathon
runners talk about hitting the wall
where it's like you've been running this
marathon and now suddenly you're like I
cannot go on and I feel that's I feel
this way sometimes when you've written
code you've got I've got this code 80%
done it's like there's only 20% left and
you're like oh my god I've put so much
work into this and now I've got this and
I know the last 20% is going to be the
hard 20% and you're just exhausted right
yours like how do i how do I keep going
and keep going at a high level of
quality you're like screw the quality
I'm just cutting corners now because I
need to get this done right it kind of
goes back to time crunch sometimes when
you're writing code the first 80%
doesn't have much of a time crunch and
the last 20% where suddenly you realize
and I think we also have this thing of
like we all know what you know we see
some good code you're like oh that's um
that's nice code actually we actually
kind of ignore nice code because it's
just like you read it and you move on
right but and and we know what wrong
code looks like you can look at code
you're like oh that's ugly
but we don't always know what the right
answer is so you know we live in this
state and even if you have a kind of an
idea like this might be the way I want
to do it you're like is that gonna be
the right way two years from now and
it's like you know so sometimes you're
just uncertain about should I put the
effort into writing this well and I'm
gonna say yes
yes you should I worked on a project one
time when we were like six months behind
and we're like darn it we need to cut
corners we need to just get this done
and then six months later we're like
tripping over all those corners that we
cut and we still we're still not done
and we're just like why did we do that
like we just made our lives worse so
often that you know for now is is
already getting your way um after
effects team has a has a macro that they
if you're if you're cutting a corner
somewhere
you put a macro around it
that's you know an if deaf around that
block of code and it's if death ship
only once and as you get close to the
release ship only once is true after
release it becomes false after like a
month after release ship only once it
turns to false all those things that you
shipped once you need to fix them before
the next release to do in a date in
constant expression nice so so how do
you get the date at compile time time
macro that would that is cool I like
that just well all you're gonna do is
change the date like it's just gonna
you're just gonna change the date on
that code like you know that's where
you're gonna need but at least if you
keep doing it you know eventually it
keeps popping up it keeps bubbling up to
the front unless you jail like one day
you're just gonna go so you're what
you're gonna do is you're gonna push it
forwards three more months or six more
months you're like oh my god we just
need to three months three months and
then one day you're like we've pushed
this forward five times either you
delete it the the guard or you like five
years
let's fix this in five years right
debility developers blind spot well yeah
it depends whether it's a warning or an
error - and I think the after-effects
one first turns into a warning and then
turns into an error yeah I I fight the
battle of getting rid of warnings in my
code base because we're at that state
where there's too many warnings so I
can't see I can't see the important ones
and and I do it's like one project at a
time I get all the warnings out and then
I turn warnings into errors it's like
okay this one's gonna stay clean and
then something changed like we changed
the compiler or something and like we
had to like turn back to warnings again
l gotta have to start all over
so but I do think we're smarter than
this so what can we do and I think pair
programming is one of the things that
helps write better code because you know
you get tired and you just want to get
this done and write the short thing and
the guy beside you is like come on you
you can you know write write this the
right way kind of thing I haven't done a
lot of para programming actually but
it's it's from what I understand it can
help here and the the Sprint versus
marathon it's like I don't like the word
sprint because if you sprint and sprint
and sprint in spirit Sprint's are good
in the sense that they take this big
thing that's going to be hard and break
it into small tasks and then you can
feel like you're making progress and can
you get positive positive feedback that
you know successful sprint successful
sprint but if it's called the sprint and
you're supposed to be sprinting you
can't sprint that long all right you
cannot sprint to marathon every week you
have to so you know maybe it's sometimes
you want to make it a relay where you're
like I've been working on this code for
a while hey can you work on this part
for me and all we're like even just I'll
work on when you're working on and you
work what not because you should have
more than one guy working on the
codebase anyhow you shouldn't be the you
know don't get hit by the bus and no one
knows the code so it's sometimes it just
helps to have someone else you know
working with you you can pass the baton
for a little while and I think this this
this whole thing I think comes back to
positive feedback and and you know
that's that's the instant gratification
gives you positive feedback and that's
why we tend towards it and and taking
time and writing good code often gets
unnoticed because like if I showed you
that you know my code of my mediator you
would just look at that code and go okay
I understand that code you'd move on you
know go oh I really liked that code
right you just you'll only see bad code
I mean especially in the code review you
look through some code you go oh there's
a spot that I need to talk to you about
so I've been trying to consciously
especially as one of the senior people
on the team one of them does a lot of
code reviews consciously look for hey I
like that code just hears positive
feedback
I'm glad you spent the time to make this
nice code and then maybe you'll write
more nice code right like it's simple
psychology and writing tests can do that
right if you write tests as you're
writing your code you feel a sense of
accomplishment it's like I've got all
these tests that pass and then I write
another API and it passes some more
tests and
you feel good about it um and even
especially it doesn't have to be the
managers and the senior people but
anyone just praise public you know in a
group of guys we have daily stand-ups
and we often have someone say you know I
was working on this and so on so help me
on it thank you just that's it five
words right that's not even praising
code it's just praising helping each
other but it's it's infective right I
are infectious what are its effective
and infectious it's effective infective
something and so our team works that way
now because it's it's gotten the
positive feedback that you know helping
others is a good thing so let's do it
so you can do the same thing with just
like hey I saw it so and so's code
yesterday I really like this thing
they've done and you know if we have to
let's start like gamifying you know
someone so removed the most coat this
week he gets surprised she gets
surprised and I think I have this thing
about visualization like athletes try to
visualize themselves you know jumping
over the high jump or whatever before
they do it
and you know imagine the code base you
want the world to have or whatever
imagine the coder you want to be and I
have to have a Bruce Lee quote a goal is
not always meant to be reached often
simply serves as a thing to aim at so
it's like don't look at the finger look
at where the fingers pointing yes no I
don't do gamification but maybe I will
start yeah have we ever we do some weird
things sometimes so maybe we have in the
past or something similar but this is
how I try to write code I try to look at
our code base and think well in five
years from now I would like that our
code base you know our code works with
and this goes back to naming as well our
code works with projectors and cameras
and we have design from the user where
the user said I want you know this is
going to be four projectors and each one
takes up a quadrant but they have to be
overlapping somewhat so that you can
blend between them and you design how
you want to be and then someone sets up
four projectors that aren't pointing
where you ask them to be pointed so
you've got your design or the theory
side and you've got the reality side and
where the projectors really are and our
job is to turn theory into
to reality make it make it look right
and and then we also have we use the
cameras to perceive what the projector
is projecting so that we can see what
reality is and so we have perception so
I'm like let's name our classes reality
we have the reality classes that have
projectors and cameras inside them we
have the theory side that is just what
the user wants our code base doesn't
have this right now and we're not going
to have it for like five years or
whatever I don't how long it's gonna
take but every step we make is going in
that direction
they're like remember that this is our
plan and and every now and then
someone's working on something I'm
saying hey that is the start of the
reality struct right there just make us
dude
don't make a fancy because we started
doing some we start designing it's like
Oh reality's gonna be a base class with
some abstract functions and we're gonna
have like different because we do
different we do to D we do 3d so we
might have different ways of sensing
reality and like oh yeah I don't like no
no just make a struct call it reality
put it put a few things in it don't
that's it just start small and and also
then don't stuff everything into it
right don't just keep piling stuff in
and don't have every function take
reality as an input take the pieces you
need other reality if you need
projectors take the projectors of the
reality pass them in but I tried to code
in a direction right okay
so there's all the cliches what's the
real meaning of these cliches and the
clash of the cliches right
what's that ambiguity yes and and also
you know I just gave you a bunch of
advice you know the opposite advice is
sometimes also true all right so you
know take all advice with a grain of
salt and I think that is the end of the
talk
you